hey maura
this is the guy this is pick dylan ew
you sent her a pic
no that would be gross he sent me
pictures of richards
that's worse tell me something just for
me
first time i saw you jed tried wrapping
his arm around you
it was a good first impression
caitlyn was cute airy hardly a reason to
pop like a zip
what happened caitlyn exploded what like
a bomb
no like a balloon what
will i give these back do you want these
back
in the hell are they gonna let us out of
here when they know it's not gonna
happen again then what's gonna happen
again
[Music]
it happened again a lot
listen everyone's scared duh duh kids
are literally blowing up
i think they're doing tests on us what's
your name for the record please
you can ask my lawyer i have a moment
for you where i knew i liked you
you liked me i'm just so glad i didn't
explode all over you
watch me
what's gonna happen to us
[Music]
school's cancelled well at least now you
can't say things were so much harder
back in my day
[Music]
you're right you have a way worse
you